magic la voit la physionomie les
expressions faciales tout porte à croire
que c'est en cause mais c'est pas tom
cruise sont hyper trucage a dit fuck
c'est ce qu'on appelle un diptyque où on
vous en a parlé plusieurs fois
l'émission première des dix fait que les
mieux fait que j'ai vue dans ma ville
apprend fois que j'ai vu cette vidéo là
je pensais que ça peut-être tom cruise
bon c'est devenue virale sur tector que
sa partie beaucoup de conversations sur
la technologie d'ipek faut juste
préciser c'est pas un dip et qui est
fait avec l'application qu'on peut
télécharger nous mêmes à la maison le ya
personne qui peut faire ça dans son
sous-sol en 15 minutes on s'entend la
personne qui fait cette patrie cage le
christ ou mais c'est un spécialiste des
effets spéciaux la personne comme dans
la vidéo c'est un acteur un imitateur de
tom cruise qui ressemble quand même
beaucoup attend cruz
donc il ya une aide énormément de
travail qui étaient mis la dalle
consumer l'homme derrière cette vidéo
ludique et ben c'est la preuve que les
diptyques ce n'est pas si inquiétant que
ça parce que étant donné tout le travail
que sa nécessité de créer quelque chose
comme ça je suis pas d'accord avec lui
parce que ça démontre comment qu'on est
capable de faire quelque chose d'aussi
bien fait quand on met le temps et les
ressources et qui sait quelqu'un pour
reprendre un acteur d'une tateurs dans
vos liens ou d'une personne connue et
lui nuire en mettant les mains le même
temps les mêmes ressources que cru
sommet a fait ce qu'on a souvent comme
réflexe est de scruter l'image de tenter
de déceler un petit défaut quelque chose
qui dépensent une couleur qui est pas
pareil est ce que c'est un bon réflexe
quand la technologie est de plus en plus
raffinés
mais justement je pense qu'on va en
avoir de plus en plus d'aider paix comme
ça et ça donne est de plus en plus
difficile de trouver des défauts dans
l'image pour dire regardez c'est un nid
par le trucage donc je pense que ce qui
est encore plus utile ces deux postes se
concentrer sur qu'est ce qu'on à l'image
de se poser des questions sur le
contexte dans les camps cette vidéo l'a
été publiés sur techtoc en cloud n'avait
pas de techtoc donc c'est la première
question qu'on doit se poser est ce
qu'ils font peser sur ce secteur
il s'en est créé un secteur qui après
que cette vidéo est devenue virale mais
on pouvait regarder aussi le nom du
contact à sion c'est 10 pts en crous
donc encore loin on a une indication qui
sait peut-être faux
puis de se poser des questions comme ça
où est-ce que ça a été tournée est ce qu
est un clown ferait vraiment des vidéos
comme ça donc se poser des questions sur
le contexte la vidéo plutôt que de
vraiment s'acharner à regarder chaque
celle de l'image pour trouver des
défauts